from always being around me and always
watching like every move I make when I
come in with the tools they're like
right in my face watching and as soon as
I put the tools down they would pick it
up and mimic exactly what I'm doing
Carmen Presti has lived at home with his
chimp Charlie for 22 years you see he
knows the difference between this
Phillips head and the the nail he
actually was pounding the hammer on this
Phillips head and he switched to your
actual cordless drill and that's what
he's working on right now are you going
a blonde locket Carmen and his wife
Kristy also have a second deaf chimp
Kiko who may have been abused by a
previous owner you like it
Carmen works full-time caring for his
primates can't you do it you are Danny
to do it and Christie has two jobs to
support the family I was never really a
primate
person per se but when I met my wife
Christie I remember her asking me if I
wanted to meet a chimpanzee that was
actually for sale and I said sure and
what ended up happening sort of fell in
love with the chimp just I gave it with
my wife the chimp was very expensive and
we ended up remortgaging our my mother's
home for the the chimpanzee Charlie a
chimp costs about 50,000 dollars and
15,000 a year to care for when Carmen's
were young both lived in the house got a
move I'm not coming in till you move
come I got a move buddy but now as
adults it's too dangerous to let them
out so they spend their days locked in a
cage attached to the prestes home when
the chimpanzees very young they are very
easy to work with please
as he focused on punch when I got
Charlie I used to bring him to the dojo
in within like an hour I taught this
chimp how to throw a left punch in the
right punch huh and it just sort of
mushroomed from there next thing I know
he was doing combination kicks what he's
about known for mostly as a jump
spinning heel kick which is unbelievable
kick he could probably throw it better
than most humans could there he actually
learned faster than almost any human I
have ever taught come on Charlie let's
eat but Charlie the karate chimp has
been retired for 13 years by the time he
was 10 he was too strong to take out of
his cage as they get older they become
very strong even at the age of like 3
they have the strength of a full-grown
adult and maybe the mind of like a
three-year-old child you're gonna eat up
their full-grown chimps are up to seven
times stronger than people and as with
Travis in Connecticut can be
unpredictable you being a good boy
Charlie he's 23
in Keiko's 22 and that many people could
actually go around full adult male
chimps fully intact canines they're not
neutered just because of their strength
and so on okay Charlie it's your turn
buddy come on Daddy's gonna feed you but
because of my love for them in my
respect for them and always being with
them they they respect me back